the nature of undergraduate education
will be deeply affected by the degree to
which the world is becoming globalized
or flat as some people call it what we
do to our undergraduates here in
Pittsburgh to prepare them for that
world is probably the most important
aspect of what CMU is doing its own
approach to globalization for our
students to be leaders in the future
they not only have to be outstanding
engineers or outstanding computer
scientists or outstanding biologists
they have to have additional skills and
talents and training that prepare them
to be special in what's now going to be
a global marketplace for their for their
jobs we see ourselves as wishing to
develop what you might call a new
Carnegie plan for undergraduate
education in which not only do we train
students with great depth and breadth
but students who are prepared for the
world that awaits them internationally
one of the things has become
increasingly clear over the last number
of years in terms of what Carnegie
Mellon is doing internationally is the
opportunity for us to pursue research
projects many of which can take place
here in Pittsburgh but in which our
partners in substance are partners in
terms of funding or coming from other
countries the scientific and research
marketplace is becoming more and more
international and one's ability to
network and connect and relate
internationally in the research mission
is going to be as important as in the
educational front
you